what's going on everybody it's warren
welcome back to the cosmic wonder where
we talk all things marvel and mcu and
tonight the moon night official trailer
is coming out so be sure to be on the
lookout for that i'll definitely be
reacting to it and breaking it down the
next day but right now we have a little
bit of news about andrew garfield
spider-man in what we all hope could be
a returning film for him a venom versus
spider-man film now i should add that
there are going to be spider-man no way
home spoilers in this video if you have
somehow managed to stay away from all of
the spoilers and you haven't seen the
movie you should click away now so it's
looking like the possibility of andrew
garfield spider-man going up against tom
hardy's venom is getting more and more
of a possibility spider-man no way home
and the return of andrew garfield and
toby maguire as spider-man and the
introduction essentially of the true
multiverse and variants with the loki
series and spider-man knowing home has
opened the door up for essentially
anything and before spider-man no way
home came out i thought that tom hardy's
venom was going to be going up against r
tom holland's peter parker and that
would be the spider-man vs venom film
but considering the ending for
spider-man noway home and considering
what andrew garfield has recently said
in some interviews i'm thinking that tom
hardy's venom is going to go up against
andrew garfield spider-man i'll break it
all down in this video but if you're new
be sure to subscribe and hit that
notification bell so you don't miss out
on any of the latest marvel videos so
when the post credits scene for venom
let there be carnage came out i thought
probably along with most of you that
it's finally here venom is going to go
up against spider-man and look venom is
in the mcu now and this happened right
after tom hardy said that he wants his
third venom film to be a venom vs
spider-man film he literally stated this
outright in interviews that's the goal
and he'd be foolish to not go for the
goal so the post credit for let there be
coinage came out we all thought alright
there it is they are actually doing it
but then we got the post credit for
spider-man no way home and it kind of
took back everything that we knew yes it
does seem like there is going to be a
venom versus spider-man film however it
doesn't really look like it's going to
be tom hardy's venom
eddie brock going up against tom hall
and spider-man it actually looks like
they're going to go more of a comic
accurate route here in the mcu a piece
of the venom symbiote was left behind in
the mcu it's going to attach to tom
holland spider-man he will eventually
get rid of it and then it'll go to eddie
brock but again tom hardy's eddie brock
went back to the sony spider-man verse
which means he's probably not going up
against tom holland's spider-man but if
this is still the end goal for tom hardy
and venom 3 then who exactly is he going
to go up against well since andrew
garfield recently returned as spider-man
he would make the most sense now at
first we weren't sure if this could or
would actually happen because andrew was
just returning for a cameo and no way
home however after no way home came out
andrew garfield got a ton of praise
about reprising his role as peter parker
spider-man he did an amazing job and he
was personally one of my favorite parts
about the film so since then you have to
imagine that the studio is wondering if
they could bring him back and in some
recent interviews he has stated that he
would be interested in coming back if it
were right if it made sense and he has
recently expressed interest in a
venomverse spider-man film here's what
he had to say about returning for other
films in a recent interview with josh
herowitz of the happy sad confused
podcast in terms of moving forward with
the character i am definitely open to
that it would have to be something very
unique very special and of service to
the audience and the character i think
there's something playful and unique and
odd and unexpected to be done i'm not
sure what it is but if we can figure it
out that would be so much fun now when i
hear him say this i think back to his
line in the movie where he says i want
to fight an alien toby maguire
spider-man talks about fighting venom
tom holland spider-man talks about
fighting thanos and our boy andrew gets
left out because he's never fought an
alien before but it looks like he might
have that opportunity here and when the
possibility of him going up against tom
hardy's venom came up this is what he
had to say that's a cool idea so it
seems like andrew garfield would be on
board with that and we know tom hardy
wants a venom vs spider-man film so
could this be venom 3 venom versus
spider-man with andrew garfield
spider-man returning once again to the
big screen i personally would really
love this and i think they could do this
in a very very unique way that would
just be super cool to see on screen and
in terms of what we have and haven't
seen on screen at this point we've seen
almost pretty much everything we've seen
avengers end game where all of the
marvel characters combined and fought
together we just saw spider-man no way
home where the three spider-man got
together i think it's about time for a
spider-man vs venom film but let me know
what you all think in the comments down
below would you like andrew garfield to
return as spider-man and go up against
tom hardy's venom don't forget to like
the video and for live updates you can
follow me on instagram and twitter be
sure to look out for the moon knight
trailer tonight and my video on it and
as always thank you all so much for
watching woof